انتهى عام وبدا اخر والاحتجاجات في ايران
مستمره حاولت ايران احتوائها مره
ومقاومتها مرات فجر فقد قتل النظام
الايراني مهسا اميني ليفجر بعد ذلك
احتجاجات عامه المدن الايرانيه وفي خطوه
لاحتواء غضب الشارع حلت ايران شرطه
الاخلاق لكن اليوم ربما عادت لتستاني فا
نشاطها من جديد بعد انتشار اخبار عن عوده
شرطه الاخلاق الى شوارع ايران وكاله انباء
فارس اكدت الخبر نقلا عن مسؤول كبير في
الشرطه عبر عوده الرسائل النصيه التي
تتعلق بالحجاب الالزاميه لاصحاب السيارات
بدات ايران ايضا العام الجديد بمزيد من
الترهيب عبر الاعدام اذا اصدرت محكمه
ايرانيه في مدينه نصر بمقاطعه مازن طيران
بايران الحكم على شيان محمدي بالاعدام
مناسب على رؤيه
ولم توقفها او ترهبها على ما يبدو اله
القمع التي يسلطها النظام على رقابهم لكن
اصواتا مؤثره كرئيس البرلمان والقائد
السابق للحرس الثوري محمد باقر قالباظ بدا
يتحدثان عن ضروره اصلاح نظام الحكم في
البلاد لكنه اصلاح يخلو من رجال الاصلاح
او قاعده
غالبيتهم او جلهم اما في السجون او تحت
الاقامه الجبريه قالب دعى الى اعطاء
القضايا الاقتصاديه اولويه وقال خلال جلسه
علانيه في البرلمان انه يجب حل مشاكل
الشعب واتخاذ القرارات في الوقت المناسب
تصريحات تذكر باخرى نادره ادلى بها قالباس
واعتبر حينها بل اعترف بارتكاب اخطاء في
اداره البلاد داعيا لاصلاحي اليه الحكم
واكد خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه ان حكومه
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي فشلت في تحسين
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه يعنيين في
ظل تراجع القدره الشرائيه وانهيار العمله
لكن كلام قالبات تصفه المعارضه بانه زر
للرمادي في العيون فلا اصلاح يتم بحكومه
متشدده كحكومه رئيس والاهم من دون اصحيين
لكن اين هم هؤلاء ابرزهم الرئيس الاسبق
محمد خاتمي المبعد عن المشهد السياسي في
البلاد بامر من المرشد الايراني
ان كان خاتمي رئيسا لم يكن الرجلان على
الوفاق بالطبع لن ننسى قاده الثوره
الخضراء في ايران عام 2009 مير حسين
موساوي ومهديك الروبي وهما الخاضعان
للاقامه الجبريه منذ ذلك الوقت مصطفى تاج
زادا مستشار الرئيس الاسبق محمد خاتمي
والذي اعتقل من 2009 حتى 2016 لتاييد
الثوره الخضراء ثم اعيد اعتقاله في يوليو
20 22 بتهمه لتقويض امن الدوله
عائله الرئيس الاسبق علي اكبر هاشمي
رفسنجاني مهدي ومحسن مع اختهم فائزه او
اختهما فائزه رفس جاني التي اعتقلها
النظام في سبتمبر الماضي بتهمه التحريض
على الشغب اذا هي دعوه تبدو فارغات
المضمون تلك التي اطلقها طالباز بعدم وجود
كل هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
تحديث نظام الحكم في جميع المجالات ضروره
يجب وضعها على اجنده الدوله والان نعمل
على ايجاد توافق في الاراء بشان القرارات
الضروريه التي يجب اتخاذها في هذا التوقيت
كما اكدت من البدايه يجب ان تعطى الاولويه
للقضايا الاقتصاديه
اصلاحوا المنظومه الحاكمه يزداد صعوبه او
استحاله بطريقه عمل النظام الحالي وفق
المعارضه الايرانيه فهناك انهيار مخيف
للعمله مقابل الدولار اضف الى ذلك الازمات
الاجتماعيه الخانقه التي تفرضها هيكليه
النظام ثم ازماتها البرنامج النووي
والبرنامج الصاروخي جاءت الاحتجاجات لتفرض
نتيجه قمعه السلطات العنيف لها عقوبه
جديده من اوروبا والولايات المتحده وكندا
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات شعبيه متواصله منذ سبتمبر اخرها
تعليق لافته كبيره على جسر في حي ولي عصر
وسط طهران تدعو الى الانضمام للاحتجاجات
كتب عليها ايها المواطن انتفض لا
للاعدامات فيما شهدت اربع مدن هي جوان رود
وسندج وساميرام واصفهان تظاهرات ضد
السلطات ردد المتظاهرون في خلالها شعارات
الموت لخامنائي والموت للديكتاتور وفي
محافظه اصفهان اعلن الحرس الثوري عن مقتل
محسن رضائي احد عناصر المسيج نتيجه اطلاق
نار من قبل مسلحين خلال اضطرابات شهدتها
مدينه ساميران الواقعه على بعد 160
كيلومترا عن مركز المحافظه
[موسيقى]
يا جوجو
حتى الان فبحسب موقع هيرانا الذي يرصد
قضايا حقوق الانسان في ايران والذي وثق
مقتل
5800 اشخاص منذ سبتمبر الماضي بينهم 69
شخصا دون ال 18 من العمر
كما وثق الموقع مقتل 66 من قوات الامن
خلال الاحتجاجات مع اعتقال اكثر من 18,000
شخص من بينهم
667 طالبا جامعيا كله اله القمع تلك لا
يبدو انها افلحت بقمع الايرانيين
المستمرين بالتظاهر في عموم البلاد
[موسيقى]